[Music]
all right
guys we've been so okay
i'm finally glad that we can tell you
this because there
is a lot that's going on behind the
scenes and we finally get to let you
know
what went down yeah so starting
in january um we got a warning on our
channel
and usually that's okay because you know
we do do edgier content and we have an
mcn which is kind of like
uh like the youtube version of a studio
or like a network and they usually help
us out because you know
the the people that are flagging the
videos or our content
it's it's usually like bots or they
misread something after that video was
worn under a warning the same video was
in the playlist
and so we got a strike which
suspended our ability to upload we were
able to only live some videos because we
uploaded them already
so we just our our video was basically
fro
i mean our channel was frozen so we
couldn't upload more content
that's right you're wondering why we
didn't upload a bunch of content for
like the last
couple of weeks that's the reason why
where our channel got froze because
pretty much when you get two strikes um
the third one your channel can be
terminated so that's where the channel
was at
and what we got flagged for was we did a
uh we did a news story
on this kid in china who like some guy
ran up to him and freaking kicked them
and like man it was really bad but but
at the time it was fine to do commentary
on news like that and whatever but since
then you know there's
been so many changes since what 2014 or
15
whatever that video was um and
and yeah the algorithm caught the
violation which was
you know endangerment to kids or
whatever some kid could have been
watching this youtube video
uh but the thing is we have just
thousands of content we've been creating
since
what 2012 i don't know we've been on jk
this is this
jk has been on youtube this is our 14th
year
so on jk news we just have so
many thousands of videos that we just
don't know
anymore because in the past we would hit
up our mcn we would hit them up and say
hey we got a strike
because this video was violated like we
want to remedy this
and they would talk to youtube and cool
we would solve this and the problem is
the rules continue to change without any
update and so i guess as creators we're
always constantly trying to play
catch-up but catch up in a way where
it's guilty until proven innocent
not the other way around because they
immediately if the bots catch something
you're guilty
we used to have our mcn that get our
backs and clear it out but now
because our mcn hasn't been able to do
anything we actually severed ties with
them so we're not even with them anymore
we're just
fireball fired them we're just
independent
but we do want to keep creating content
we do want to keep this entire operation
going on
which is why we've decided to move
majority of our content over to patreon
this whole company the all of jk
we create content and we have editors we
have
people that produce that manage the
channel the whole like 10 or 15 people
the whole point is to create content for
this channel and we're
pretty much one straw away from this
whole operation shutting down first and
foremost
this is at the end of the day a business
right
and although we do have other businesses
and
um it doesn't make sense for
it to be subsidized by other businesses
and and for for us to keep going on this
but
for me like jk has a huge
place in my heart as not just a business
but a lifestyle like it's a community
it's like our country like we we've
been in your guys's phones like
houses like rooms like you watched us
every day
for some people more than 10 years yeah
it's a place for us to share
our personal stories share our
embarrassing quirks sometimes
and be able to connect with a lot of you
guys and this business has nothing to do
with the other businesses like they
don't like joel saying it doesn't
subsidize each other
and we want to be able to continue to do
that so we feel that
patreon is probably going to be the best
place for it because i have one set of
rules
once we're clear with them then we make
sure all our content follows those rules
and the rug isn't going to get pulled
out from underneath us one of the things
we've been brainstorming is what if we
bring jk party back
you know not uh we'll have a couple more
videos a week of jk party maybe even ask
the feels
so pretty much gathering all of the best
content that's really reflective of what
jk has been
and give all of it like a home and a
place where we can be that much closer
to you guys but here's the cool thing is
that we're not going to be completely
moving off of youtube and for those of
you
who still want to watch us and you can't
afford the patreon and all that that's
totally understandable
we wanted to figure out a balance and
we're still gonna be doing off the
records
and hopefully with this new stuff with
the axe ask the experts and stuff like
that we can keep that on youtube
but unfortunately if you're the type of
fan that like to watch
the three plus videos that we posted
every single day
we're gonna be putting those up on
patreon yeah and
um they did notify us that the strikes i
think we have to wait until
may until they get removed but you know
with staff and running an actual company
we can't just sit around with that one
like well one strike left and risk the
entire
operation getting shut down so we have
to make the move now
and go over there but we're still
fingers crossed
that hopefully that um those strikes can
still get removed
and um but that's the reason why we want
to be on patreon is so that jk can have
a safe home to be
at yeah but at the end of the day i
think
no matter what we've survived for so
long and to me
it's pretty nuts like if you just think
about it right like cockroaches of
youtube
we are we are not only us but the
we're not we're not really anything
without the people that watch us and
keep this alive
right and then the community like beyond
this if covet was wasn't around every
year we would be doing shows at like
universities we'll be doing meet and
greets and all this stuff
at the end of the day the jk family the
empire like the whole world that we
created together
and then seeing you guys face to face
that
is probably the most rewarding thing
that i would like to continue doing
until the end of time until you guys
don't want us anymore or whatever at the
end of the day i feel like
what's awesome is the community that
we've built and we got to continue that
back in 2014 it was pretty crazy when we
did jk news
right at the time jk films was our main
bread and butter but every time we
posted a jk news video
people were like i wish instead of it
being
three days a week i want to see this
five times and we would do that so we
said you know what let's
crank out as many jk news as the people
want but it got to the point where we
created this routine
and after a while it
was really starting to burn us out
without realizing
that maybe our content was hurting a
little bit but now
we have a different direction we want to
take i think i want to do more
of a quality thing instead of a quantity
thing when we
experimented with patreon in the past we
were just uploading
just a little bit more controversial
things it's kind of like the same thing
but for those of you who either were a
part of the patreon in the past
or you want to really get that content
again
this is going to be fresh and new
exclusive stuff so that's what i'm
really excited to do because
i personally miss doing jk party with my
friends
now we created a way where we can make
everybody happy
and it works out perfectly so let's be a
part of this
go ahead check that link in the
description box below watch the videos
and i'll see you guys there because it's
gonna be super
fun see you guys there bye
do